no king h4
provocation he wants alireza to deviate
no he wants to draw
alireza
makes his move gives the check again
going back is it going to be a
repetition of moves or a leader as a
ghost queen these rebooters i could
claim now with rookie one
he won't would never claim he just makes
the move he will either play rookie one
or play queen d3 say let's keep going
but i think he's had enough i think what
he wanted i think it's safer to go and
he goes away
you know rajab is hesitating should i go
king h4 one minute on the clock
or let's try something
claim it
stop the clock
see yes there you go
i know timer
he does he doesn't mess around
without making a different move after
after king h4
and after seven hours and one minute of
play they agree to draw with a very
funny move repetition i must say
it's not very often happens that with
queens on the board you have the black
king on h4 rook h1 king g5 repetition of
moves
no i can't recall that many games with
this
but franchise is the oldest participant
in age and firoza is the youngest
participant in age
yeah
may count sometimes when you have a very
long
game but look ali reza is smiling he's
in good mood he tried didn't work out he
loves the game he had a fun day